[Music]
what the
what what is this stuff
that's drying foam sealant i'm going to
kill this kid
you don't mess with me a little
[Music]
you think you're cute you love from the
world of pain my friend
you'll be sorry that's when you're cute
this will never be spoken of no idea
what you're talking about
can i help you sir you can help me find
maria oh maria's gone we're completely
self-checkout now
please scan your item please scan your
item i just did please scan your item
yeah right
can't keep happening you're not putting
me in a home
what if it were our home grandpa
hi grandpa hello sweetheart how's your
daughter's place that she gave me my
grandson's room he's not too happy about
it how do you like your room
kid look i didn't want it to be this way
either i just want my room back
get away from me ah come on
i want to put up with this piece i
demand my room back or else it's more
declaration of war give me back what is
mine
face the consequences okay okay
you got your wish what the fast drying
foam sealant
i'm gonna get this too so let me get
this straight you want me to help you
and your buddies
help beat up your grandson and his
buddies because the two of you can't
figure out some way to live in the same
house well when you put it like that i'm
in
this kind of aggression shall not stand
senpai
i don't know you were a marine
just saying let's do this
do you guys even remember how to play
dodgeball so you don't need your diaper
changed
sure you don't
[Music]
run for your life why are we doing it
this way
when you have peace talks you need
someone neutral to mediate
he gave me a cookie it is true a cookie
was given
i think your grandpa might be a ninja we
gotta end this somehow
did you see that
[Music]
so
bye